Yeah,
it is a delight to be here at Tech Mecca
talking with you all about this very
important question. Um, uh,
a question that is simple, huge, soulful,
strictly scientific techie
meaning of life size.
And it's a question that
we ignore, shirk, skirt,
ridicule and pretend we've
answered when we haven't, uh,
fold. Family friend and I were
catching up with each other and um,
he asked me what I've been up to and I
described the question to him and um,
he balked in a telling way. He said, uh,
it sounds like you've got way
too much time on your hands. Uh,
it's way over my pay scale.
It's a question that
can never be answered.
And it was answered last week in a
Facebook post about quantum consciousness.
So I got all four of them from him
at once. It is a simple question,
much simpler than any of the
things that you deal with.
And yet it is a fairly
unfamiliar question.
People do tend to balk at this question.
So the way I'm going to do this is I'm
going to frame the question and then
pause for challenges.
Kicked the tires on this thing.
Really try to get clear on the
question, challenges, questions,
all of that and then give
you a new proposed answer,
which is unlike anything
I've seen from other sources.
The question is what are striving selves?
I strived,
therefore I am, you know, Descartes
said, I think therefore I am,
I'm going to go much deeper than
that. I strive, I try, I make effort.
This doesn't make effort. Computers
don't actually make effort. They do work,
they do very useful work, but they don't
make effort. They don't, not striving.
And I'll be more specific
about that in a minute,
but you can call us any number of
things. An agent, organism living,
being on, I'm just going to call ourselves
and I'm going to call us all selves,
that every one of these
organisms is striving.
It is doing work for its own benefit.
Striving means not going with the flow.
And you can see that here in this, uh,
self,
um,
going upstream and it's,
it's more than this.
It's more than just going upstream
because really what's going on is we are
going against the flow
towards the degeneration,
everything falling towards entropy,
randomness disorder falling apart
and petering out. So very simple,
straightforward question.
We don't,
we run to stay in place like the Red
Queen in Alice through the looking glass
and it's happening right now unconsciously
and unfelt striving like what our
bodies are doing right now.
Right now my body is regenerating itself
faster than it degenerates and it's
doing it without me understanding what
it's doing or any awareness of it.
Just like it doesn't bacteria that is,
they don't have consciousness,
they don't have feelings and yet they
are striving against the tendency to
degenerate.
So really we can distinguish
between two kinds of things.
The things that exist lasting as they
degenerate depending on their durability
and selves, which persists.
Striving to regenerate.
Very big difference as yet unexplained
by the sciences. That's the question.
And as I said,
machines are not striving selves.
We engineer them for durability.
Computers aren't striving cells and
striving cells are not computers.
I adore computers. I live on them.
I'm spend most of my time on them.
There's not a luddite talking.
I'm not protesting against the use of
computers as low. They are heartless. No,
I think they're full of heart the way
I use them. But they are not striving.
So the question comes down to this,
there's no magic added and yet
selves are means to end striving,
not just cause and effect mechanism.
There's something different about
us from nothing but chemistry.
So I rule out from the start the idea
that there's some magic nom thing thing
either gets to deposit into matter
that makes us come alive or soul,
the spirit of vital force or any of that.
None of that will work
nor will the argument.
But there's something about all
interactions, all material interactions,
all cause effect.
That's actually a little bit means to
ends and you collected enough of that up
together and suddenly poof, poof.
It's a suddenly a striving self. No,
I'm ruling all of that out.
And also I'm ruling out the argument
that all we are is cause and effect
mechanism, which really does
corner with us with a challenge.
What are striving selves.
There's a fundamental gap in our research.
Scientific research striving selves are
inadmissible in the physical sciences.
If you had a physics professor who told
you that the moon strives to pull on the
tides for someone's benefit,
you'd think there's something wrong.
But down the hall you've got a biologist
or a social scientist who can talk all
they want about striving selves.
So there's this fundamental rift.
Take these three terms,
absolutely essential in biology.
You cannot do biology without functional.
Basically function
fittedness and striving.
That's about selves.
That's about selves engaging in
what I'll call self directed work,
effort by selves for themselves,
responsive to their circumstances.
Now the way it works for continuity in
the sciences is that the lower level
scientists have to explain what the higher
sciences assume and we got a huge gap
here.
There's chemistry does not
explain functional fitted
striving and yet we totally
rely on it in the life
and social sciences.
Okay,
so approach I'm going to propose
promote is that you start with strivings
patient zero,
the very first striving self.
You have to explain how
mattering could ever from matter,
how you ever get from chemistry to
even the most basic striving self.
And if you do that,
you get to reveal the bare essentials
without all of the best bells and whistles
that accumulate through evolutionary
history. You start simple.
That is not how we tend to do it. We
tend to do it through cognitive science,
which starts way too high up.
It's like trying to
explain hair from quills,
porcupine quills they are
hair consciousness is very,
uh,
it's,
it's very much a striving selves
property just like quills are like hair,
but it's very specialized and it's
highly evolved and it's also a little bit
cognitive science like trying to explain,
striving,
starting with wigs,
which is an artifact or computer as an
artifact by which we can try to determine
what it is about us that
is striving. Um, you,
you've probably heard of the hard
problem in consciousness studies,
which is how do you ever get quality
of the experience, the feeling,
the sensation of things.
But cognitive science works from a
computational model for what living is.
So I consider it the made harder problem.
If you're gonna try to
go from computation,
which is not striving to do anything
and he goes straight to quality,
you're going to have problems. That's
why I suggest we start with patient zero.
That is with the very first
possible striving self.
And I'll say this is a question behind
our biggest questions to reckon with
consciousness, mind, quality of
freewill, morality, mortality,
spirituality, uh, astrobiology et cetera.
Start by explaining how the first
striving self could emerge from chemistry.
So here's a mystery laid
out. Um, we've got names,
we've got names for what selves
are for their properties,
for their behaviors.
We've got nouns and adjectives and verbs
and they all remain as yet unexplained
by these terms from the physical sciences.
So you could call us organisms,
subjects, agents, individuals,
living beings, creatures,
you can even call a spirits or souls.
It doesn't actually
matter what we call them.
These are names that flag
what has yet to be explained.
They just are markers that we use to say,
this is something we have yet to explain.
Um,
and you've got all of these properties
and all of these behaviors as yet
unexplained in the physical sciences
saying that you are striving self is no
more a scientific explanation
then saying you have a soul.
Both of them are just markers.
So naming is not explaining.
Here are some solutions that we often
move towards since we have this gap and it
goes on explained and um,
I'm going to suggest that they don't work.
Natural selection.
Just an idea out there that there's
the universe was rolling along with its
natural laws and then suddenly a new one
enter is called natural selection and
suddenly it gives rise to organisms,
doesn't work.
Natural selection is actually
natural degeneration.
Itselves failing to self regenerate.
It explains the honing not what not
what's honed to say that natural,
it's a selection explains life is like
saying that erosion explains mountains.
Yeah. Explains how they're
sculpted but not what they are.
So I want to say natural
selection doesn't start life.
Life starts natural selection.
You actually have to have striving selves
before you have evolution as we think
of it.
Another idea is molecular replication
in particular RNA molecules because they
are so important to us organisms now.
But the idea is that you would
get molecular replication.
What you've got here are examples of
molecules not being created from scratch.
It's conservation of matter,
it's transforming of molecules.
So you get these molecules, um, going
through their chemical reactions,
but the chemical reactions
can appear to strive.
But then so can anything a river can look
like it's striving to get to the sea.
And actually chemical reactions like
that are just going with the flow.
So this idea that molecular replication
somehow solves the problem will not do.
And the energy gradients degenerate first.
They paid her out.
You saw that in these two
examples I just gave you.
But the material order can remain
the generating more slowly.
It's still not striving selves.
How about jeans?
Jeans,
sometimes it's used for the molecules
themselves as if a DNA molecule is a gene.
But mostly what we mean by this
is sequences within the genes.
Sequences are not striving selves,
but interpreted by them.
DNA, if you lay it on
table, is his lifeless.
So to argue that it's the secret of
life seems to be missing something.
It's not this magical molecules. It's
sometimes to pick that the secret to life.
So little like saying the text,
which is also a sequence is
striving to tell you something.
Another striving self is telling you
something with their text but the text
itself is not actually striving
to tell you anything. Um,
or the alternative which is that it's
just cause and effect relationships as if
the sequence, the genetic code which
yields a one to one correspondence.
A code is, is a material cause and
effect process is somehow all there is,
which is another popular notion about it.
Want to be clear on this.
One of the places where we get messed up
on this and in the scientists and also
in philosophy is to treat
it all as causality.
Interpretation is not causality.
A stop sign doesn't cause you to
stop unless you crash into it.
We stopped because we interpreted,
given our strivings,
that's about traffic for our benefit.
So interpretation is radically
different from cause and effect.
Okay.
Complexity reason.
I have a frog on the cover of my book
is that in the book I pose the question,
which is more complex,
a frog or a frog smoothie.
Now technically a frog
smoothie more complex,
there's poor correlation and
there's almost no correlation
between the molecules.
Once they're all shaken up,
once they degenerate it with a blender,
but also they would degenerate anyway.
Um,
that's actually more complex than the
frog. The frog has more regularities.
It would be easier to describe
which is the metric for complexity.
So we often get ambiguous with this.
Um,
is it more complex or
just harder to explain?
The frog is harder to explain and yet
less complex. It's, it's regularization.
It's the orderliness,
orderliness within a frog that is so
impressive and so hard to explain.
How about Ai? Not Striving but
engineer trained to aid our striving.
If you connected a Julian AI super
computers on a sterile planet,
what do you get?
You get a sterile planet that is no
quantity of AI by itself is going to yield
you striving selves.
Quantum mechanics,
quantum phenomenon doesn't strive.
Striving cells persist of the
classical non quantum level.
Like jilted lovers. Many researchers
would rather not discuss it.
The dance around the gap by equivocation
basically talking out both sides of
their mouth. I read these glorious
books by your neighbor. For example,
Robert Sapolsky,
who wrote this wonderful book called
behave all about the biochemistry of
motivation.
I love these books and yet they
are still dodging the question.
He'll talk about how a
molecule causes a motivation.
It's not clear how that happens and
he doesn't seem to be addressing it.
You get a book like information,
a theory, uh, uh, what is it a a,
a history, a theory of flood
by James Gleek wonderful book,
which by the end of the claims that
there's information everywhere and has
always been by the end
of the middle section.
And then he goes into the last section
about how we're now experiencing a flood
of information,
which is it?
Is it always everywhere or is it
something we can experience a flood off?
If we experience a flood of then
apparently we are interpreting it in a
different way than we used to.
But the claim that it's all information
is a kind of equivocation information
could be true,
talked about it.
So it's just Shannon reductions and
possibilities or as a difference.
It makes a difference for a self
that is striving to stay alive,
to regenerate.
Okay.
So that's the question and I want
to hear your challenges to it.
I want to hear you really kicked the
tires on this really pushed back if you
have trouble with the question or if I
haven't been clear about the question and
then I'll go on to a new
proposed to answer. Uh,
no intentionality would be
a subset of striving. Um,
the words get really squirrely in here.
That is a carry a lot of baggage.
I'm in my last presentation or bio
semiotics conference, I called it trying,
which tends to imply a kind of a
psychological intention, a wheel,
a conscious effort.
Um,
so I've ended up gravitating to
striving because for two reasons. One,
it's fairly clean on this
question of ghost and machine.
There's a tendency in this research,
I think of it like walking a tight
rope line. This question here,
because you can fall off into ghost,
basically Hmong Cuellar that is you're
anthropomorphizing what goes on or into
machine mechanics causing an effect.
So how you ride that is difficult
with the words we've got.
There are definitions of intentionality
that would be broad enough that it would
cover what all living beings do.
But that's not the vernacular use of it.
And we usually think of it as something
willed by a conscious feeling being.
But yes, it is included in
here. And, and, and by the way,
I am not just striving to regenerate.
I'm striving, for example,
to communicate an idea that is by now
humans have all sorts of head room and all
sorts of distractions,
other kinds of intentions.
But if you want to get at patient zero,
you start with the most basic,
which is pushing against
this tendency to fall apart.
So you mentioned,
uh,
artificial intelligence and the
limitations thereof that you,
you could hook up a large number of
artificial intelligence and machines and
that you would still not get a striving
self out of it. Nicely put. Um,
one of the ways that we
understand artificial
intelligence today is just a whole
bunch of the linear Algebra
and neural networks.
And that is very much a calculator.
Are you,
are you saying by that that artificial
intelligence of today could not be
constructive? That, or
could it be never? No.
Actually saying up today,
and this is an important point,
it's actually my takeaway that is
once you understand patient zero,
you have a new angle on AI,
which I wouldn't know about
because I'm not an expert on it.
But I do think there's potential for it.
And there's someone in the audience
who's paying close attention to that
potential. Um, and Tom,
right here. There we go.
Yes. Thank you. Yeah. It's just not yet.
So are you counting viruses as striving?
We're not. It's a great question.
And I would say yes, but to do that,
I can't just work from impressions.
I have to give an argument for that. So
it's a difficult argument and debatable.
It's not, it's not altogether clear. The
model. I will give you four patients.
Zero is like a non
parasitic virus without DNA.
It's really gotta be simple and yet not
impressionistic to do it. So it's uh,
but, but yes, there is something
about them that does seem,
we talked this back and forth,
me and this guy, uh, colleagues,
including John and Anton,
we explore this and wonder about
whether viruses count or not,
but we think they probably do.
Yes.
So regarding your slide on jeans,
yes.
How would you respond to
the idea that, um, uh,
chicken is an egg's way of making another
egg and that it's not the DNA that is
the striving,
but rather
the coupled system between
a ribosome and the RNA?
Well, even still, if you
put robbers on an hour,
hour and a naked on a table, um,
they're not going to be striving self.
So there's wood, but, but
you're onto something.
One of the things that life has to
do is it has to replicate. Um, and I,
it has to reproduce.
I use,
we produce rather than replicate because
replicating the kind of thing you can
do, um, without paying attention
to the work involved. You know,
those chemicals we're
replicating in effect over there.
No reproducing takes work. So we have to
explain the work themselves. Do you know,
we'd go back and forth between saying
I have this body and I am this body.
I'm going to argue that
what I am isn't my body.
The body remains there after I'm dead.
It's still all right there and the energy
of the material of the organization
and yet I'm gone.
So I have to be able to explain
that and not resort to Phantoms,
not resort to ghost.
This is the challenge.
This is what I'm going to try to do
in this next little bit. Um, but yes,
you take a sequence or you take a
coding process extracted from biology,
it's not the striving self either.
It just got to keep on.
It's a process of elimination saying,
well,
and that's basically what I was going
through with those solutions that don't,
each of those have been tempting and
I'm arguing each of those. Don't cut it.
Okay. So let's say you have
a very simple organism,
like a non parasitic virus that
you mentioned, which is a striving,
uh,
now if we could simulate that
with sufficient fidelity,
would dissimulation then be striving.
Uh, I'm delighted you bring that
up. I want to propose a, uh,
a contrast between
simulation and emulation.
Simulation is done with cause and effect,
uh,
formalisms schematics, that sort of thing.
Basically Arrows and pointers, you know,
moving from node to node
by my version of it.
That is you are modeling the consequences
of some behavior emulating would be
actually showing how the behavior works.
And it's different from modeling it.
And I'm going to give you an example
of the slide two slides after.
This is going to be Anton's emulation
of the process I'm describing.
If you can emulate it. Yes, you're well
along to being able to understand it,
but you have to work with the world as
it is and it's not a bunch of cause.
An Arrow affair, uh, uh, Co, uh,
causing an effect arrows and nodes where
you get to label the node and just talk
about them as pointing this way.
I'll be saying a little bit,
but more about this emulation,
I'm going to argue with
something different and
totally achievable at Google.
So that's one of the reasons why I'm
interested in presenting here. Okay.
I mean,
well we'll see,
but I don't completely buy the difference
between simulation and emulation.
It's good. Like a good
10. I haven't yet really
delivered on it yet.
So let me see what I look forward to your
questions and challenges after. Okay.
Okay, thanks. Okay, so
this is Terrence deacon.
I had met him, uh, shortly after this
book had come out of the sandbox.
BCC has been 20 years as a neuroscientist
at Harvard trying to on understand the
emergence and consequences
of us having language,
the symbolic species. And he had
just moved on to another question,
which culminated in this book in
2011 called incomplete nature.
How mind emerges from matter.
Um,
famously a challenging book to read,
difficult to read.
So my effort is to distill it
and some of this into my book.
Um,
I think of them as a natural philosopher,
which is what scientists
were originally called. Um,
he's a scientist and yet he's
dealing with philosophical questions,
questions that scientists often don't get
around to like what is a striving self
or how does language actually
emerge? Um, he's also,
uh,
a very easy person to talk to.
We have a meeting at his house
every couple of weeks. Um,
open to whoever is interested.
That's how Anton got involved. No,
Anton Anton actually read,
uh, in incomplete nature
and decided he wanted to ma,
uh, model or emulate, uh, the
process that he proposes in here. Uh,
John also joined up through that,
through that meeting.
We just get together and explore this
stuff. Um, it's delightful. It's easy.
It's apolitical. The guys never
pulled rank on me in 21 years.
We just talk. We work on the
problems. It's a delight. Um,
so here's the question.
As I posed it before,
striving selves are something different
from nothing but chemistry. What?
Starting with patient zero.
And here I'm going to give you a
grotesquely simplified solution.
It's a chain reaction that
generates chain reaction seeds.
I'm not sure the Terry would like that,
but it gets at it.
And here is Anton's beginnings
of the emulation of it.
That is he's imagining a chain reaction.
Um,
he's modeling a chain reaction with all
of the stochastics involved and these
seeds forming along the way.
Um,
they are color coded to represent there
in effect viability and this is very
early days for this research, but
he sees this as a possibility. Um,
we,
uh,
for how we can get at the narrowing in
on the kinds of molecules that might have
made this process power possible.
You'll notice it.
I said that these were something
like non parasitic viruses,
but there's no DNA in these things.
The reading of sequences in the
service service of your striving,
it's not the kind of thing you can imagine
easily coming about spontaneously out
of chemistry.
It's a very complicated process.
Terry has a model for
how we could get there,
but we're starting simpler than that.
And as I said,
simple but not impressionistic.
Okay.
Now let me back up and
tell you how I got there,
how we get there to your two don'ts.
Basically your experience of life,
you focus rather than dithering.
You could've done dozens of other
things right now during your hour here,
but you chose to be here.
Um,
and you're not just everywhere
you're doing focused work.
Your focus is a product of self control.
Everything you prevent yourself from
doing consciously and unconsciously and
above all, you focus on preventing the
degeneration of your ability to focus.
So I'm going to be arguing that you are
a prevention that prevents itself from
ending.
It's a process of elimination logic,
very different from the Arrow kind
of logic we use in schematics and
formalization. Um, and it's the insight
behind a lot of very big breakthroughs.
Um,
pay attention to what's eliminated.
Darwin natural selection
to explain fitness,
attend to the non survival of the unfit.
Shannon signal theory to explain signals
sent, attend to signals not sent.
Ashby h Ross Ashby who coined the term
self organization to explain increased
order.
Attend to emergent constraint on disorder.
I'm a have to say more
about emerging constraint.
Here are two quotes from him that I like.
A lot of self organizing system
spontaneously reduces the number of its
potential states. Observe what
might have happened, but did not.
Here's an example,
an intuitive example of it,
the threading through a crowd and
others threading around you. Um, uh,
you'll get these strings of people who
are taking the path of least resistance
that emerged by a process
of path elimination.
Now these are striving selves,
so it doesn't really count, uh,
if we want to look for patient zero.
But there are of course,
plenty of nonliving self
organization processes.
Now the term self
organization is problematic.
We were talking a minute ago about
problematic terms like intention.
It suggests a self trying to organize it
and there are plenty of people who have
moved in that direction.
Talking as though if you just get
self organization going and it gets
complicated enough, then you've
got to striving self. Um,
I actually call it emergent
regularization. It's a constraint process.
And whirlpools are an example.
Auto Assembly,
like a crystal formation and auto
ketalysis about which I'll say more now
because they're essential to our model.
I don't want assembly is
basically crystal formation,
but all sorts of other processes as well.
Lipid membranes for example,
which are bubbles. Um, uh, or
capsules which will be crucial here.
They're like viral shells. They're
not actually constructed deliberately.
They're not part of the striving process.
They actually fall together
just like crystals do.
They fall to resting states and the
resting states given their complimentary
molecular geometry, um, will
yield you regularize sheets,
shells and tubes.
So these are very exciting.
Remember we're trying to
figure out how you get,
how to explain the frog while
the frog is full of regularity.
So we might look to this process.
Auto assembly as a step towards life
towards striving selves auto could tell us
is basically a chain reaction that grows
a population of multiple catalysts that
are all in effect producing each other.
It's a population explosion that grows,
depletes the resources that it
depends upon and then dissipates.
So if you imagine you've got
these two molecules, x and Y,
and in this super simplification of it,
they are both transforming reactance.
I didn't get specific about the
reactants into more of each other.
An ex transforms an hour into a why and
our why transforms an into an x and you
get this population explosion of xs.
And Ys,
but in the meantime you're depleting
all the r's and you end up with a
dissipation of the molecules.
And the thing about this auto
could tell us is is it's,
it's more likely to start if you've got
a cluster of the xs and ys to start it.
Yes,
it could start with one x producing one.
Why they wouldn't then produces another x,
but it's way more likely to start if
you've got a cluster of them in close
range. And often with
byproducts, for example,
an x might split an hour into a y and
some other molecule which also be crucial
to this explanation.
A self organization.
So like I said, some people think
that self organization is enough.
It's a variation on the
complexity argument.
If you get enough of this kind of
emergent regularization self organization,
suddenly it becomes a striving
self. We don't think so. Uh,
it goes with the flow towards
overall degeneration and selves.
Don't they strive to regenerate,
but still this concept of emergent
constraints that is reduced possibilities
emerging throughout a dynamic
process is of interest to us.
And we think there's a
way to get at the origin,
the the patient zero of
striving self through it.
So just to be clear on
the general principle,
the whole is less than the sum
of its parts possibilities.
Any of those people threading their way
through the crowd could have moved in a
whole lot more directions,
but those directions are reduced through
the congestion and they ended up taking
paths of least resistance at some
probabilities become less likely,
others become more likely.
What's presented is a
product of what's prevented.
And so we got that throughout the sh
the Darwin Shannon Ashby are all playing
with this key insight.
And basically what we're doing
is applying it to this question,
what is the striving cell?
If it's not your body, if
it's not your DNA, ribosomes,
what is it?
So we think of self regeneration
as possibly a higher level
emergent constraints.
So we've come up with a testable
hypothesis for how coupled self organizing
processes could prevent each other
from ending. And like I'd said,
it has to be simple and yet not
impressionistic. I don't get to say,
well that looks like it's striving.
It actually has to be doing work on its
own behalf, fit to its own environment.
Okay.
Requirements for self generation. Very
basic. If you, if you're thinking about,
okay, uh, everything's degenerating, how
would you keep yourself from degenerating?
You'd need self-repair regenerating,
whatever degenerates you'd
need self protection that
is preventing to generation
and you'd need self reproduction
because eventually you will degenerate.
And you need lineages of a self
regenerating striving selves that have the
capacity to self repair and self protect.
And out of these three,
you end up with this
interesting challenge. Um,
what I'll call selective
interaction. Uh, we all deal with it,
but it had to be there
at the beginning of life.
That is in order to do any
of this generative work,
you need to take in energy and
resources and put out waste products.
And at the same time to prevent the
generation, you have to not do that.
So you've got this going on
from the origins of life.
And that's a challenge for origins
of life research because um,
the kinds of selective membranes that we
all rely on that led in some stuff and
not others,
pores and orifice was and all that,
you're not going to get that by chance.
Just a lucky chance that
lets in all the right stuff.
Let's out all the right stuff
doesn't let in all the wrong stuff,
doesn't let in all the wrong stuff.
That is a origins of life theory and
origins of striving cells has to be
striving successfully
outpacing the tendency to
degenerate from day one that it
has to be able to do that. And this is a
challenge to select of indirection. Hey,
by the way,
you're still doing all of this.
Obviously self-repair you're
striving to keep fit and healthy.
Sometimes consciously, sometimes
not consciously. Um, uh,
self protection.
You're regenerating skin staying
closed with a roof over your head.
Self reproduction kids may
be and selective interaction
which has gotten very
elaborate for human beings as a little
taste of it in this room right now I'm a
suggesting something that you can either
absorb or avoid. People do all the time.
We're always trying to figure out what
to take in and what not to take in. Um,
at many levels from you can say the
immune system to our mouth. All of this,
all of it's still going on.
So here finally is that model that we
show that I mentioned early on and we got
the emulation of it from Anton.
Here it is the auto gen
meaning the self regenerator.
Imagine you've got one of those chain
reaction process is the auto metalysis but
it's by product happens to be
one of those caps had molecules.
So while it's chain reacting in
the midst of that chain reaction,
it's putting out molecules that will form
the equivalent of virus of Shell's not
trying to form them, they just
formed, they fall together.
That's the auto assembly.
So you've got a complementary charity
between the two where you get a chain
reaction.
Um,
and then you've got these shells that
encapsulate what I called starter kits or
seeds that if they break open and the
presence of more reactants can resume the
Orica Telesis the chain reaction and
resume producing seeds. Okay, so take,
let's take a look at this.
You've got the reactants.
You've got a cluster of these catalysts
in here. The purple are the capsules.
It breaks open.
Let's say a big molecule hits it and
it's got spill out into the reactants,
which generates a whole lot more cs,
x's and y's that ended up by happenstance,
captured within more of these shells.
That's the seeds or starter kits.
Very simple model
is there.
Self regeneration well is repairing the
seeds as they degenerate and the capsids
protect against the generation.
It generates varied an evolvable
audit, auto, uh, auto gen lineages,
and they're selective
interaction though not quite.
It's not actually choosing
when to be opened and closed.
I'll explain how we get there in a minute,
but at least you have an alternation and
the alternation is crucial given that
one of the things that has to fit his
environments where reactants are only
sometimes present,
we think of this thing like a ratchet.
It grows for a while and then it
locks down while it's locked down.
It can survive in environments
where there are no reactants.
That's why it's useful.
Dev seeds were starter
kits that are enclosed and
basically static at that point.
So it's functional in that it's self
repairs when broken for its own sake.
Remember, here's what good place to
not be thinking about intentionality.
It's not trying to, it doesn't
care. Um, it's not conscious.
It's not willing all of that.
And yet we have to,
we have to start at that level if we're
really going to understand that the self
repair benefits, the lineage
of audio autogens, um,
it's fitted as I've mentioned,
it's striving when seeds are broken.
Autogens respond with auto catalytic
work that regenerates seeds.
Okay.
Here's an example of how it might evolve.
We argue that at this point you have found
a way to outpace the tendency towards
the generation.
Um,
okay.
Breaks open other molecules get into it.
We have discovered a way in which you
can self purge. That is, it will get,
tend to get rid of molecules that don't
facilitate it. It breaks open and uh,
the molecules or copy or the x's and y's,
uh,
not the other molecules that are
kind of strays that enter into it.
So there's a little bit of
self purging at this point. Um,
but imagine that you end up not with a
y but a z and the z happens to have a
different by product,
a different caps and molecule that's a
little rougher on the outside and the R
is actually stick to it.
Making the overall seed refer
more likely to break open.
Okay
now this is the kind of
thing we can emulate. I'm not
saying this is the answer,
but it does show the kinds of things that
it could evolve and it is big isn't an
attempt to show how from nothing but
physics and chemistry you could actually
get a striving self that would
then have the capacity to evolve.
So when it breaks,
you can see that this one actually begins
to have selective interaction is more
likely to open in the presence
of reactants. Then, uh,
in the absence of app of, of reactants.
And then as I mentioned earlier,
we have a model for how you'd
end up with a template molecule.
A molecule like DNA or RNA that has a
sequence that is actually functional for
the striving self. But we would
argue, given the complexity of, of,
of making use of a sequence,
you really have to start with striving
selves if you're going to get to the
level where you can actually
use DNA or RNA. Okay.
So what's a striving self?
It's not a ghost.
It's not something added to chemistry.
It's not mechanism.
It's not the material energy causing
an effect work or organization.
It's a self regenerative
emerging constraint.
A synergistic coupling between two self
organization processes that prevent each
other's degeneration.
Okay.
What is the self then?
What is a striving self?
If you were to work all
the way up to all of us,
I would argue that we are a constraint
that channels energy into work that
prevents the constraints,
the generation and that it came about
through a synergy between two self
organizing processes that prevent each
other from ending your whole is less than
the sum of your parts.
Independent possibilities.
So I come back to emerging constraints
because I think it may have the most
application.
And thinking here about how to move AI
and other technologies beyond where we
already are to really push it.
Um,
observe what might have happened but did
not emerge. Regularization as I said,
self organization is go with the flow.
Local temporary generation of
energetic and material regularities.
Emergent self regeneration though is
self striving against the flow to prevent
their own degeneration.
And it happens through this synergistic
coupling where both of them stop the
other from failing auto
ketalysis remember it,
it grows and then dissipates.
Well the capsids keep it from losing all
of its potential before it dissipates.
And capstans will break
open and dissipate as well.
But the auto gen replot replenishes
the supply of caps had molecules.
These molecules that form the shells.
In general though, there's a
methodological question. Uh, our,
our proposition I want to make a life
isn't schematic or formal like our
engineering and math simulations.
It's running gauntlets selves constraining
possibilities to prevent dime.
It's somehow figuring out how any
organism does anything like this,
running through the constraints because
it is fitted to the constraints.
It has internal to itself, uh, a, uh,
an agency that enables it to avoid
all of the risks of the generation.
And in general weeks, I find that
across the fields in philosophy,
in programming,
they just across the fields were still
using models that in one way or another
and apply a point a to point B.
Kind of a Euclidean approach that I'm
going to say is not quite how it works.
Everything is random at the start.
And somehow life figures out how narrow
in on possibilities it's processes of
elimination. Okay. So just these two
takeaways to push the tech envelope,
pay attention to how tech simulates
but doesn't yet emulate striving cells.
And Th that's the thing we can talk about.
And the other is to attempt to emulate,
pay attention to emergent constraints.
Nasca chromatic airway, but dynamic
narrowing of possibilities. Thank you.
Okay.
Anybody have any questions and challenges?
So one of the interesting consequences
of the way that you've presented this is
that,
is it you,
you mentioned it works on multiple
levels at the immune system level or the
organization.
Is there any bias in this for,
I'm observing this at any particular
level because you could look at it from an
aunt, sell you an aunt, um,
organism as we understand it,
to an ant colony to the super
colony that covers California. Yes.
Versus humanities,
a cell or a person standing
here or their neighborhood.
Community of society.
Yes.
Wonderful. Um, great question. Uh,
the people who are doing this research
come at it from a variety of different
angles.
My background's in the social sciences
and most of what I write is in the social
sciences and yet it's all under the
influence of this model. By now, I mean,
the thousand articles I've
written, they're all based
on this, the political work,
the moral work I do, it's a psycho
proctologist it's all based on this.
In our own research though,
we keep focusing on patients is zero.
We are kind of obsessed at that level
and we also have people who come into the
group with some intuition,
some gut,
a assumption that they want to
uphold their kind of tethered to it.
And they come to this work,
like it's a Rorschach blot.
And they start to say, wow,
this proves that I was
right about this thing. Um,
I am delighted with how we manage to
keep that from influencing the work.
And a lot of this is because,
uh, Terry is a nerd. He's,
he's dogging about this question.
He wants to get it right.
I've seen him change his mind lots.
I've changed his minds about things and
he's way more advanced academically than
me. He's not interested in the status
questions. He's, he's not interested in,
I don't see in him any
ax to grind. Um, yes,
he would like life to
continue striving. Um, but no,
I haven't seen that influence with it.
We've got some biologists in the
group that are primarily interested in
multicellularity.
We've got all sorts of people who are
interested in the implications of this
narrowing, not airwing approach, um,
to all levels of living systems. Uh,
we've got a few guys who are really
interested in whether organizations are
organisms and um, yeah,
they can look like it,
but are they really? So we, we
have foster about that a lot. I,
I at one point was writing
as though they were,
that there were these super organisms
and Terry laid out the challenges to that
because it gives that impression
that it probably isn't a,
let's look at what is the criteria by
which you could say that something is
actually a striving self as compared to
an agglomeration of striving selves that
are achieving things.
So I love the way we employ the power
of neutral thinking to the best of our
abilities.
And by the way,
you cannot work in science without the
possibly that you will have spent your
entire life barking up the wrong tree.
So I have no idea whether this is right,
but I am enthusiastic about the way that
it addresses a question freshly framed.
Um, I feel a little bit like, like, uh,
like you've reduced,
uh,
kind of the original question to something
which is a lot more tractable and
cause less satisfying question.
But um,
for a bigger question,
where does consciousness fit into this?
Well, Terry is a neuroscientist. He's
got theories about their, their hunches,
about how you, you'd actually
get to quality and consciousness.
I just got back from the a annual
Tucson conference on the science of
consciousness.
And it's remarkable how much they are.
They are talking as though
everything is conscious.
And then there's some
kind of a quantum leap.
It crosses a threshold and then
becomes conscious in ways we recognize.
And you got people who are saying that
there's no consciousness and there's
people who are talking about it
coming out at the quantum level.
All this stuff very satisfying. I
don't think realistic at all. Um,
so it's one of the questions
that we deal with, you know,
Terry having spent the first 20 years
working on how language affects junk
consciousness.
I have hunches about consciousness
being the really big difference and I'm
especially interested in how it changes
adaptation that his life has been
adapting for 3.8 billion years and now
we're doing it under the distorting
influence of language,
which makes us like these chronically
hallucinating mammals with all sorts of
interesting consequences, positive and
negative, and how to manage them become a,
it's a focus of another
whole book of mine. But, um,
satisfying is a really
key word here. Um, yes,
in many ways this has to be simpler.
There's, you don't get any engineering,
you don't have life already existing
and you don't get the delight of the
impression that you have discovered
how life as you experience it works.
Um, it's, it's going to have to be
a simple solution at this level.
And yet I would argue that
whether you buy this solution,
this proposed answer to it or not,
that's the level to work on it.
Because if you cannot
explain striving selves,
you are not going to be able to get beyond
explaining hair with wigs or quills.
You're your way up at the high levels
and assuming or assuming a way,
all sorts of stuff that the lower levels,
is there a point at which awareness
or awareness of awareness becomes
significant or important to you? That's
another area where we explore. Um,
uh, we think that basically what
we're describing here is what,
what Terry calls vegetative sentience.
I don't like the word sentience
cause it implies feeling. Um,
I like responsiveness.
He and I've been working on how to
find words that don't carry a bunch of
baggage and yet nailed it.
Um, uh, so responsiveness,
there's responsiveness
from the Gecko with these,
if they break open their respond by
doing work to regenerate themselves,
uh, to repair themselves. Um,
then there's feeling which is more
like sentience and then there's
conceptualizing these are the three that
are of greatest interest to us. And yes,
there are a bunch of wonderful articles
by Terry and colleagues about how it
works at the higher levels. But
again, for this presentation,
I've really wanted to concentrate
on patient serio zero,
because if we can't explain them,
uh, we're groping in the dark.
I take it to more of it.
That word is death on to that cycle of
each generating and like the statue.
Wonderful question. I,
um, I am Chrono phobic.
I am Chrono fillic. Um, deaf fascinates
me. I memorize poems about it.
Where does it fit into this model?
Um,
what is dying when one of these breaks
apart or opens in the presence of
reactants?
What's dying is not the material form.
The material form can actually change
over openings and closings. That is, uh,
several generations down
the line. One of these, uh,
seeds may have no molecules in
continuity with the original one.
Um, and it's not the energy, the
energy is coming from the outside. Um,
what is being lost is the constraint.
When I die,
my molecules are free
to do way more things.
Life is not an add on to physics
and chemistry. It's a subset.
It's a self constrained subset that is
me reducing the possibilities as long as
I live. And as those, uh, the,
the synergies by now through evolution
accumulated vast quantities of synergies
like the one we started with,
the complimentarity where they both
prevent each other from ending.
We do that all the time in our bodies
at so many different levels. It's a,
it's a marvel, it's many Phd's. Um,
but what you lose is the constraint
and suddenly the molecules are free.
Um,
I read recently then Brown's
new book on origins of life.
Um, uh, and he tries to make
that a pretty picture. Um,
like as if,
uh,
everything is moving towards entropy
and that means that they're free.
And that means that they're shining
their light everywhere in the world.
That is not how entropy works. Um,
entropy. It's things falling apart.
And if life was about maximizing entropy,
which is also a popular notion
in his book, Jeremy England
brings this up, um, uh,
then let's just explode the
soccer. I mean there's, uh, if you,
if you want maximum entropy, there are
faster ways to do it, then we do it. Um,
we living beings,
we actually sequester energy.
That's one of the reasons
why we've got petrochemicals.
So the thing to pay attention to here
was trying to get to in the last two
slides is that what I am is
a constraint on what happens.
And when that constraints starts to fail,
I lose my agency.
And at that point I'm dead.
And the molecules are free
to be in a whole lot more,
uh, uh, uh, configurations
and often with offspring.
In fact,
my fellow grandfather of by
grandchild is right here.
Talk About Oscar is my first
time at heck a tech Mecca.
I am delighted to be here.
I'm grateful that you were able to give
me your attention for this time and do
feel free to get in touch
about any of this if,
if questions and challenges and kickings
of the tire come to you tonight or
anytime I'm around. Okay. Very local
in Berkeley and thank you very much.
[inaudible].